[Musique]
et regardez moi
enfin qu'est ce qu'elle fait je suis
massenet après ac vous là c'est moi oui
quelle heure est il
9h57 monsieur 10 alors déjà non monsieur
demers 57,6 à l'âge de monsieur où on
n'en est pas encore à trois minutes près
au mien on l'est hélas diviseur le sua
peur de manquer son train et vaccins en
général qu'on écrit en sont pressées
comme ça et qui sont nerveux c'est
qu'ils sont un train à prendre et qui
trop embrasse manquent le train et ses
gars là qui colle ou qu on m'en parlait
pas monsieur quand on a une femme dans
la peau je plaisantais monsieur et ça
vous fait rire ça je suis plutôt de
nature est lié et comme l'on dit si tu
es guéridon
on sortirait jamais mois par cette façon
là en tout cas eux j'aimerais bien vous
voir à ma place que d'eau que d'eau
comme disait maintenant c'est maintenant
on me dit ça j'ai un remerciement sur
les éditions mais comment est ce que
monsieur a pu faire pour être en paix
écoutez si on vous le demande
permettez monsieur monsieur n'y arrivera
jamais en tirant de toutes ses forces
dans cette chemise
l'essentiel c'est de tirer tout
doucement comme cela arrive au même
écart légèrement à l'écart de people ont
fait leur it is et là monsieur je ne
supporte pas sa vie sauf les pales seule
fille avant l'autel si ça ne bouge et on
est obligé de vous avez la chemise tout
en primeur un peu de calme tranquille on
se décontracte voilà monsieur regarder
on est clairement et voici attention up
attention frontières un petit peu là hop
et d'une élémentaire monsieur blé goudé
merson n'ai plus besoin de vous alors
qu'on aimait à faire dessécher puis
ramenez moi tout en dix minutes bien
monsieur pour me précipiter ainsi dans
l'otan monsieur ne seront certainement
pas compte de l'état exact de ces avis
enfin je veux bien essayer pour rendre
service à monsieur mais je vais me
réponds de rien c'est moi je ne voulais
pas contrarier monsieur mais j'étais
bien certain que monsieur n'y arrivera
pas tout seul je n'y arrive pas à me
soucier la manche 3 quand je ne suis pas
embaucher à paris dieu nous avait demain
c'est pour nous servir aussi bien de
lune que de l'autre il ne faut jamais
remettre à demain ce que l'on peut faire
avec une seule a dit non le passez votre
temps à me faire rigoler
venez donc mais dès que ça va coûter un
maximum à monsieur de ça mais monsieur
n'hésite pas à frapper un lâche je n'ai
pas beaucoup qu'on fixe le prix des
services comme moi mais monsieur ne m'a
pas écouté monsieur je ne parle pas des
services que je vois je pars le tapis
qui commence à saint pie et d'une façon
dangereuse dossier permettez monsieur
voilà attention attention et hop
hall je remercie monsieur est revenue
que vous attendez là et bien les choses
étant ce qu'elles sont j'attends portant
de monsieur et je ne me vois pas comme
ça
l'église monsieur malige lui à quel
messe à la biec monsieur se marient et
et bien écoutez si vous n'y voyez pas
d'inconvénient allons monsieur non non
non non non non non la tapisserie de ce
fauteuil est très ancien monsieur vaut
une fortune
si monsieur tient absolument à s'asseoir
qu'ils aillent de faire dans la salle de
bains où il trouvera deux tabourets
auvergnate
bon moi je viens de comprendre l'état
d'humidité avancé de monsieur monsieur a
sans doute voulu cette nuit enterré sa
vie de garçon et ses amis l'euro en
matière de plaisanterie douché tout
habillé ça se fait encore un peu éculé
mais enfin ça fait rire on va chez de la
cicta non si monsieur veut m'écouter
voulu bouder comment moi j'ai encore
emma les garçons alors là monsieur
problème et moi vous êtes bien valet de
chambre
oui monsieur onf rappelé oui monsieur
alors dites-moi quand on est valet de
chambre et qu'on frappe
oui monsieur ben on va bien entendu
à
merde alors oui les noms placard ok je
me souviens bien que ce qui fait
l'angleterre parce que monsieur il n'est
jamais plat car pour bien faire il a du
retard dans le placard ah oui pasquale
écoute p1 c'est pas toi que je veux et
voilà c'est le titre que je dépose et
gagne demi-heure bordeaux tél oui aussi
monsieur je veux parler du 245 monsieur
le trouvera dans la salle de bain
derrière lui il probable
sans blague ils ont que faire du
compartiment c est un cinglé à la
maniaque ainsi folie de la flotte
1 enfin quoi il est tu vois ce que je
veux dire une espèce de poisson c'est
pourquoi ça non je m'excuse monsieur le
pantalon c'est pour moi ah bon c'est
vrai ça je vous remercie mes pairs et
dire que je lui aurait donné le bon dieu
sans confession
mais que voulez vous je l'adresse de la
personne et qui est dans ma voiture et
qu'on m'avait demandé de ramener chez
elle m'écoute je ne sais pas demandez
lui comme la personne en question est
vite l'émotion lui a fait perdre la
mémoire
je vois pas très bien comment après en
sortir et je vais vous dire monsieur moi
j'ai une femme une femme et cinq enfants
nourris alors j'ai vraiment pas une
minute à perdre
sans compter que mon taxi maintenant
c'est une c'est une vraie piscine très
bien combien c'est pas moi c'est pas mal
fixée à 300 francs sont encensés pas
falloir avec la détérioration de mon
taxi fils temps perdu c'est c'est plus
14 400 d'accord 500 mais ces mois
derniers prirent leur à condition que
vous me prenez et il me débarrasser ces
personnes emmener là où vous voudrez
n'importe où pour réunir pour voir des
d'accord cochon qui s'en dédit et
cochons c'est mon nom à monsieur payant
les kits allez pas vous avez le non non
j'ai donné ma montre a réparé hier et le
prenait l'eau à écouter ou plaisir de ne
plus jamais vous revoir
ils parient à grand-bassam sera facile
il suffira d'éviter la salle à la bc oui
oui oui
et comme vous savez les dents passé pour
la flotte
je vous conseille d'aller à versailles
bah pourquoi versailles les grandes
zones direct
bon alors saucette leach commises après
je suis maçon
oui quelle heure est il j'ai dit à
monsieur il ya deux minutes qui était
exactement à vous dégoûter je ne vous
demande pas alors qu'il était il ya deux
minutes je vous demande l'heure qu'il
est maintenant ça vous fait rire non
monsieur le client est roi
il est 10 heures exactement monsieur
très bien dit qu'on allait chercher mon
paquet de cigarettes que j'ai laissé en
apogée mon pantalon trop tard monsieur
sous l'effet de l'eau les cigarettes de
monsieur on fait comment dirais-je
cataplasme bien alors allé m'acheter un
paquet de blondes
il ya je ne sais pas si monsieur a lu
l'article dans le journal hier matin ils
ont parlé des cigarettes les différences
entre les brunes et blondes dans les
blondes il ya deux à trois fois plus de
nicotine
également il ya beaucoup plus de gouttes
de good de goudron où sont mes habits
j'ai mis les deux femmes de chambre de
laitages dessus et de temps en temps je
jette un coup d'oeil monsieur l'appeler
besoin de moi non bien mais passe ici
donnez moi votre nom
non monsieur prêté en or me suis donné à
fond j'ai prêté une montre un client je
ne les ai revus ni l'un ni l'autre je
suis mari de ne pouvoir rendre service à
monsieur j'espère que monsieur me
comprends bien alors venez me dire
l'heure exacte toutes les 10 minutes
bien monsieur alors actuellement il est
10 heures une minute et dans les minutes
il sera exactement et ça suffit oui que
bien que monsieur semble le croire
je n'ai pas le cerf volant le cerveau
mais j'aime m'amuser mois vient enfin de
voir mike aussi eu un monsieur qu'au
quatrième top il sera exactement
10h02
[Musique]
ce qu'il ya encore où je viens aux ors
et bien qu'elle dort pas perdre les
vôtres c'est une plaisanterie c'est pas
parce que vous appelez ça une
plaisanterie et ben oui les chauffeurs
de taxi maillot rouge sur la tête qui va
faire quand il va s'arrêter qu'il verra
plus dans sa voiture vous n'êtes pas de
taille phenom les petits gars est un bon
jour
dommage quand j'ai vue du chauffeur
démarre elle centre lui donner l'adresse
j'ai tout compris alors j'ai attendu le
premier embouteillage et je suis désolé
mais côté de vous trémousser comme ça
vous dégouliner partout acolytes dans le
rialto dernièrement pharma a longtemps
alors on aurait pour annoncer la
tapisserie 13 enchaîne ce qui vous a dit
ça
bah le valet de chambre eh ben il s'est
foutu de vous jeune homme j'ai horreur
qu'on m'appelle jeune homme mais je
faisais ça pour vous être agréable où ce
que vous pouvez m'agacer vous et moi
j'en ai encore interdite non c'est pas
moi qui suit vous cherchez aussi dans la
salle vient d'écouter bien meilleure fac
est ce qui vous a trimé de quel droit
vous êtes venu vous a posé comme ça
entre moi et le néant cette façon
d'attenter à la liberté des gens est
inadmissible
voilà au mais non écoutez écoutez
broothaerts cinq minutes et l'écouté
c'est marrant une autre robe mais ne
l'est plus j'avais décidé de nourrir
alors j'avais soulevé mon appartement
distribuer mon argent à des oeuvres
c'est cadeau de ma garde-robe à mes
meilleurs amis et dieu sait si j'en
avais des aigles dérembourse et bah
écoute et oleg alors reprendre on me dit
on de néons prendre n'est pas dans mes
habitudes
roger fois
toujours une fois banal comme par hasard
juste je suis en temps d'attraper une
congestion et l'importance mais voulait
mourir alors il est voulu mourir mais je
veux pas être malade j'ai une peur
épouvantable de la maladie mais bon
bien merci jeune homme
[Musique]
bah ouais vous laisser ces jeunes est
oui oui nous avons tendance à refroidir
à 10h10 monsieur merci monsieur s'est
blessé au genou ces projets du moment
qu'on sait que nous en plus on voit rien
ça ne m'étonne pas monsieur le monsieur
qui occupait la chambre avec monsieur
avant monsieur avait un petit ami qui
était comment dirais-je couturière nous
avons eu beau passer l'aspirateur
cigarettes
oui monsieur je suis désolé il ne
restait que les brunes
où en sont mes habits et bien les pans
sont à peu près 7 mai que deux revers
avec les revers
décidément j'ai eu la chance avec
monsieur même mes genoux vont les plus
subtiles enfin dommage de bris écoutez
vous si dans cinq minutes je n'ai pas ma
inquiète mon pantalon et mon gilet jouve
est avéré c'est beaucoup et c'est tant
mieux
eh bien vous attendez n'ai rien monsieur
il est vraiment un peu grande pour moi
même excusez moi je ne pouvais pas
prévoir ou jam un très grand chose mais
bon je ne prévoyais pas en tout cas pas
vous souvent elles vous avez raison les
années 20 il ya plus qu'à songer au
moyen de limiter
asseyez
je prends le temps au niveau d'apple une
honda nous venons si je me marie dans
une demi heure
bon alors ça c'est inouï
inwi pourquoi inouïe mais disons amusant
non mais écoutez madame vous êtes au
courant du grand événement qui se
prépare alors vous me facilitez auriez
matin lorsque vous appelez ça une tâche
à bien
mais moi si j'étais votre fiancée
j'apprécierais pas beaucoup cette
expression c'est pas moi là pour la nuit
aulas me plais pas vos deux rouges par
hasard non pas sur moi aussi je me
maquille le rapport est vrai que vous
faites là juste pour qu'on aille nous
racheter tout ce qui était dans mon sac
et qui par votre faute empoissonnent
maintenant les pauvres petits poissons
obtient au poids savez c'est entre vous
il va les rendre l'esprit est à
l'honneur ainsi vous allez vous marquent
bien
bah quoi piot ben je vous demande si
vous faites un beau mariage mais
sûrement pas mariage d'amour c'est bien
vous avez raison dans l'intérêt même
souvent plus loin tapas et vous dites
j'irais bien mobilier oui je vous prie
de bien vouloir sortir mais où ça mais
n'importe où vous serez m'en fous sans
vous je serais morte
vous ne l'avez pas voulu et maintenant
vous avez la prétention de vous
désintéresser de moi et de me jeter
dehors de force mais ce serait trop
facile mon grand mais savourer les
obligations vous comprenez damman j'ai
horreur de l'hôtel infos que vous ne
trouviez la porter
jusqu'à maintenant j'ai été calme
oui mais je vous préviens je suis à vous
et si vous continuez à vous incruster
plus longtemps je me verrais pensée de
vous faire je déballe humilité entrée 1
10h22 monsieur les deux minutes de
retards sont imputables à un client qui
bégayait il des t il des dd il désirait
un kaka kaka que j'ai mis dix minutes à
comprendre que cette attaque a fait
monsieur mason mais non c'était moi s'il
vous plaît est ce que vous pouvez me
faire chercher du rouge à lèvres de la
poudre de riz un savant à la violette et
un flacon d'eau claire de chez sweety
j'ai tout inscrit sur ce papier
mademoiselle et trombone à coulisse
mademoiselle et connaissent je remercie
mademoiselle bien entendu je mets cela
sur une autre note naturellement merci
non mais ce que vous rendez compte de ce
qu'il ya de de compromettant dans vous
mettrez à tour notre norme régional
sylla nous risquent d'être compromis
sais pas vous mais moi d'accord mais moi
moi je me marie quelle heure est il
aucun renseignement à ce sujet ma pauvre
montrer ton fond place non non c'est ce
qui ma pauvre marie marguerite approuvé
par hasard ce qui n'est pas mais ce que
son comportement pourrait faire croire
d'ailleurs pendant que j'y pense il va
falloir que je note tout ce que vous
devez me remplace veulent en mourait de
chacun alors un bracelet montre en or
massif incrusté de diamants
parce que vous portiez un bracelet
montre incrustée de diamants à 8 heures
du matin
ouf une barrette incruster des mro une
bague en platine incrusté à bourgoin
vous avez la main et respectable
eyeos que je ne dis rien moi aussi tu
utilises chercher allons chercher
chercher nous allons chercher chercher
un comme personne ne pourra jamais
vérifier ce que vous partiez un modèle
de votre blonde joue alors aller 6 1
n'hésitez pas à pas ce que vous ne
faites pas confiance
bah je sais pas engagé un homme
grenouille
mais qu'est ce qu'il fait c'est imbécile
avec mes amis parce que vous pensez
vraiment encore vous marier ce matin
quoi de la manche notamment montrent
notamment
mais cette optique on aurait dû booster
les symptômes président est en tout cas
vous n'avez empêché de faire tout à
l'heure simplement pour avoir le plaisir
de mettre des grands coups sur la tête
si je vous ai donné quelques légère tape
sur la tête pour vous empêcher de vous
des barrages vous avez en revanche les
dans les tibias quelques grands coups de
pied en vaches dont se porteraient
longtemps les marques en vaches vous
allez dire lorsque la wii du dimanche
alors vous m'avez obliger à vivre malgré
moi pour venir deux heures plus tard me
traiter de va mais qu'est-ce que j'ai
bien pu vous faire moi pour que vous
vous acharnez ainsi après moi parce que
c'est moi ah ça c'est la mer
ça fait trop mal et ne supporte pas
il est à noter que l'hôtel après 10h30
messieurs voilà là le maire a commencé à
s'impatienter et l'envoyer dans une
heure sont attendus curé comme l'on dit
après ce report a rendu maintenant on
est bien tous deux fini de rire comme un
imbécile et puis vous pleurez alors
ressembler mais mes habits ils vont
mieux mais ce qui est beaucoup mieux
mieux de penser à leur écoute et aller
les chercher
j'ai qu'il allait mieux je ne sais pas
s'ils sont tout à fait rétabli mais je
vais quand même aller voir monsieur est
ce que mademoiselle veut que j'en
profite pour demander à la femme de
chambre de venir pour l'aider à mettre
sa robe de mariée
mais je n'ai pas à bon port ce mari
comme sa nature juste paf pas bien passé
moderne c'est vers ça peut plaire ça il
a cru que c'était moi là bas vous verrez
comment vous savez je ris parce que ça
vous déplaît que je pleure reprendra son
égalité 1 1 à l'aller a passé une fois
je passerai sur un pompage fermant les
yeux puis je me coucherai les oreilles
je suis trop malheureusement je veux
mourir
c'est en effet la meilleure solution
parce que ont poussé au suicide
or en taxi l'a 7 des cas de minutes non
ah ben non elle non plus jamais cette
eau sale et boueuse baird bon écoutez il
ya cent façons différentes de supprimer
tenez l'hôtel 15 étages remonter en haut
passé par dessus bord y'a plus qu'a t il
tomber
ah bah non non non ne partirai pas des
plus folichon le suicide n'est pas
forcément une partie de plaisir
oé oé oé alors la télé qu'est ce que
c'est rigole m
moi c'est ça
oui c'est ça mais moi j'aurai pas m'en
servir malin tout comme sa muse simple
trait ça vibre vous mettez le bout du
canon à gauche je raccroche soutien
gorge mais c'est pas tout tient gorge
non pas non plus
un clou plafond encore doré près vous
après le cordon et puis le monde sera
débarrassé de lambert 2 ab qu'est ce
qu'il fait cette année si la guinée
nettement je suis en train de prendre un
retard aux objets trouvés au on peut
dire que j'ai de la chance j'ai eu une
chance inouïe et je suis insomniaque
belgique
je suis obligé de temps en temps de
prendre un comprimé de garder la halle
alors là vous avalez le tube est là
pour l'éternité est entré voilà monsieur
monsieur est peu dire que pour lui
rendre service et femme de chambre et
moi même nous avons fait berline
enfin je veux dire dirigeants sortirait
pas à moins d'une demi-heure bird bon
une fois je ne serai pas le cas en vain
il est 22h40
mais dans quelle étagère
oui alors qui monsieur pierre rolland 1
mais je ne le connais pas moi
comment c'est à part de qui de sa
fiancée ah bah écoutez je sais pas mais
je vais voir un kit est pas vous appelez
comment mr bayahi si vous êtes général
cambronne
on va écouter moi j'essaie de vous
répéter ce que monsieur pierre rolland
ma vie vous dire comment qui je suis
mais qu'est-ce que ça peut bien vous
faire maintenant fait pas la femme de
chant aux eau eau alors ma pauvre ami
c'est vous la malheureuse et ben je ne
connais pas mais je vous plains de tout
mon que si oui d'accord
ne quittez pas je vous la pelle c'est
bien vous bien rolland mais c'est ce que
je dois dire à votre fiancée et la wii
ce téléphone
allo darlin 12 avril dernier
non non non darling les cépages darling
darling ne pleurez pas darling le
support de la spécialité de faire pour
aider paris
la gale femmes à celle qui vous a
répondu
c'était là la femme de chambre darling
mais je vous assure darling mofaz
darling entre cette femme que je ne
connaissais pas qui vous dit qu'elle est
la femme de chambre et et moi qui vous
dit qu'elle n'est pas la femme de jambes
j'espère que vous n'hésitez pas il vous
en aviez en plantant parce que si vous
ne me croyez pas aujourd'hui qu'est ce
que ça va être de taille comment voulez
vous que je le sache darling ont raison
elle vous a dit qu'elle n'était pas la
femme de chambre oui une seconde darling
je vais lui demander comment un bon pari
oui et bien veut dire qu'elle vous a dit
qu'elle n'était pas la femme de chambre
parce qu'en réalité elle ne l'est pas
elle est légère incroyable non et bah
écoute et n'ont pas non plus c'est pas
tout le général et bakel général bah oui
c'était un général anglais mais ils
goûtent et darling ne nous mêlons pas
les affaires des autres
oui darling je suis bien je suis un peu
en retard un bon papa pleurs et
belle-maman crient ils écoutent et dites
leur que je leur apporterai un havane et
des bombes au citron à vous à mérida
darling sida l'hymne là vous avez ri
darline je vous dis que vous avez ri
j'ai entendu darling vous avez déjà
entendu
darling la mairie da il coûtait darling
puisque je vous dis que vous écoutez
d'herning je serai à midi à la mairie au
revoir à tout de suite dernier j'arrive
gwadloup a pa si je suis ni
habillez-vous nus dans l'eau mans vous
fasse école est bien là sortez le temps
de me sécher et je suis à vous sentez je
compte jusqu'à 5 et j'appelle la police
le constat d'adultère j'ai déjà une demi
heure de retard à cinq minutes de plus
ou de moins bien sûr que vous vous en
foutez vous beau-papa manchon si gareth
bale moment les citrons ce que vous
attendez pour aller calmer mon bouton de
faux col pardon aux boutons de faux col
mais qu'est ce qui lui est arrivé à
votre bouton de faux col les jours la
tablette du lavabo à droite du gobelet
quand on sort de la baignoire et c'est
pour ça nous fait toute cette comédie
tenez mais lâchez moi mais vous êtes
fous mais vous lâcher bon ça n'est tout
de même pas la prétention de me voir
tout ni au beau tout ça y est quand même
pas la première
ouah ouah ou médée vous attaquer pour
coup et morsures mois 11h10 tous des
balkans c'est parti
jamais jamais jamais alors mon beau
pyjama maintenant le beau salut que
j'avais mis de côté pour 2009 j'y
arriverai jamais vous permettez je viens
oui oui oui oui mais bien au consulat du
paraguay quoi combler ces grèves au
moins là-bas la belle étoile à paris
je suis venu j'ai pas du bouton démarrer
faccioli drire comme une imbécile venu
dans médée écouté puisque vous me le
demandez sur ce tour et le bouton rond
la voilà à assombrir vraiment pas le
temps de faire mumuse voyage en grèce où
il sera à un sourire c'est à prendre ou
à laisser un
[Musique]
c'est charmant quand vous souriez vous y
arrivez vous vous répétez la main c'est
pas grave
à combien vous m'avez dit que je dois
prendre le comprimé de gardénal si je
veux bien dormir un tulle non je veux
dire juste pour un bon petit sommeil
réparateur un ou deux comprimés écouter
pour les endroits comme ça on sera
débarrassé vous pour un petit moment
ap 2-3
et demi
oh
ce que vous êtes mais bon il est dommage
que pantalon enfin pour écouter j'étais
enchanté de faire votre connaissance pas
en pyjama
vous n'allez tout de même pas attention
moi partir rester ici parce les vous que
j'aille en pyjama à l'internet haut du
corps est heureux d'avoir
considérablement
j'apporte les produits de beauté de la
demoiselle non merci
autre série mademoiselle il est 11
heures à monsieur je sens que je vais
prendre un bouillon
quelle chance je vais enfin pouvoir me
laver avec un savon possible maquillée
et me parfume et chamonix tube all i
believe
il ya au monde qu une emmerdeuse ou sur
mer deux salles du gardon me sens moi tu
connais tu m'as les chevaux dit je suis
maudit monsieur modique
je suis panique
il est bon libre et en plus c'est moi
qui devais repêchés quand je vous dis
donc je vous dis je suis maudit ouais
j'ai eu beau dit c'est que j'étais viré
mois sous la terre vit rue je vais la
faire virer je fais alors mademoiselle
prier mais immédiatement le directeur de
monter au 245 s'il vous plaît débat est
il grand effort commun mais dit dans vos
jeux vos faut qu'il ait les yeux bleus
je veux dire pas de briller aussi le ne
portait de prioriser le portier prier
aussi le portier de mortiers jamais
ou alors elle sort - mine de rien
[Applaudissements]
j'aurais dû y penser plus tôt
non je viens du corps et qu'est ce que
je vais faire du tort bon mais qu'est-ce
que j'étais le corps ou est ce que
j'aime avec le corps mauvaise que jamais
que le commande le corps ou est ce que
je vais mettre comme parler tout seul
c'est inquiète ces bouges pas mettre le
camp
m
oualalou
namor n'y avait pas les no no no no de
ben ali tout nouveau d'origine online
woods voilà voilà
allez mon doudou le mot doux doux voilà
un panneau nous si j'ai pa modou le ben
ali dont nous prenons pas moi de mon
doudou pas dodo
voilà et mon tout nouveau maman oui
mademoiselle vous ne vous ne trouvez pas
le directeur de l'hôtel
aucune importance tout est arrangé il
est maintenant il a dû simplement à
cognac dans lequel j'avais mis trois
comprimés mille gardénal c'est tout et
demi
pour lui il est minuit la et minuit il
est minuit les minuit docteur schweitzer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est toi c'est moi qui toi j'avais le
valet de chambre et vous me tutoyez je
n'ai pas du douanier monsieur je vais
pas les sétois génisses et moi c'est
tout il ya pas de quoi
quelle heure est il 8h30
c'est bien aller chercher mon petit
déjeuner si j'allais à la cuisine un cas
mais le petit déjeuner à 8h30 mais si on
prendrait pour un fou et bave au coin
si les huit heures toi monsieur du soir
sur 20h30
monsieur ne me vois pas d'ailleurs c'est
l'heure de théâtre ce soir si je puis me
permettre
qu est-ce qu on joue je suis barré
monsieur je n'ai pas regardé le
programme mais je me suis laissé dire
que les décors étaient de roger hart et
les costumes de drague cardwell
qu'est ce que j'ai à voir légitime
puisque ça mon vieux monsieur ne
s'inquiète pas ce sont mes claques quel
jour sommes nous vendredi monsieur 20h30
qui nous marier aujourd'hui monsieur va
bien monsieur va mieux
monsieur est bien vivant oui à l'hôpital
y cirrhose du foie
ça va emilie 2010 est à as tu peut pas
se passer 22 dit s'il te plaît oui ça va
toi et le gosse en sapant sa liberté à
pacy 22 10 le léopard a souri à la puce
je répète le léopard a souri à la puce
et vous ça va bien même si ça va très
bien ça va bien mais pas à me plaindre
c'est pas un robot le léopard a soumis à
la plus monsieur c'est le code que nous
avions convenu convenu avec la fiancée
de monsieur comprendra un fiancé de
monsieur que monsieur était encore
vivant à bercy alors et si j'étais mort
dans ce cas je devais dire le renard a
pataugé dans le clafoutis mais une seule
fois
ça vous fait rire oui le renard a
pataugé dans clafoutis ça me fait rire
c'est de moi alors que le lieu a pas
rassurés la puce et de l'ex fiancée de
monsieur c'est moi bon ben ça alors
déchéance et oui mais c'est pourquoi
l'ex fiancé je dis cela à cause des
parents monsieur autant je crois que
monsieur pourrait retrouver le coeur de
la jeune fille c'est le désirez autant
je crois que ce serait dur avec les
beaux-parents parce qu'ils sont venus
ici pendant le propos le profond sommeil
de monsieur et d'ailleurs ils ont
ramassé quelques fleurs et quelques pas
qu'il y avaient ils sont venus
oui monsieur dino village
la robe de quilles monsieur monsieur je
suis on va parler de la jeune femme que
j'avais pris pour la fiancée de monsieur
et qui en réalité n'était que ça
mettrait pas plus amusant est ce que
j'avance et je le regrette pour monsieur
car elle était bien bel et bien d'accord
tu es en plus un sens de l'humour pour
avoir le sens de l'humour mais elle me
le pea dans cette banque
elle n'y est pas non est ce que monsieur
a pensé à regarder dans la baignoire
non elle n'y est pas non plus en plus
[Musique]
monsieur l'a retrouvée morte en pyjama
tarbes est là elle est sortie nue pour
un possible monsieur je sais qu'il ya
beaucoup de va et vient dans cet hôtel
mais si une personne avait traversé le
rôle nu je leur ai vu excusez moi
monsieur
j'ai voyagé alors alors même moi
monsieur je n'y comprends rien téléphone
monsieur oui
oui oui
ah oui mais c'est bon on vous réclament
au 200 m 2 ah oui c'est le consul du
base alors de cuba de cuba c'est la même
chose mais enfin l' avantage avec lui
c'est qu'on avait six gars si monsieur
vient de permettre au parce des gentils
sa gelée légèrement emprunté au consul
merci je ne fume pas de ce pain-là
monsieur mais mieux vaut tard que jamais
un cigare de ce prix enfin on croit
rêver du réverbère
enfin
el ouazzane veuillez me passait pas si
van den dit s'il vous plaît à l'eau bon
bah pas à raccrocher la loi moselle
veuillez me repasser pas si 22-10 s'il
vous plaît à l'eau ben amor elle
raccroche à l'eau mademoiselle oui eh
ben on a été coupée allo darlin j'ai
comme l'impression qu'ils veulent pas
parler moi
on a fait un bon dodo je vous conseille
d'éviter ce sujet alors là vraiment je
vois pas de quoi vous voulez parler mais
j'insiste pour vous sentez vous dire de
chez le coiffeur de l'hôtel
naturellement j'ai fait mettre sur notre
note naturellement québec deux ex de
lynx de la fermeture la note mais non
rassurez vous je lui ai emprunté à la
femme du consul d'afghanistan va plus
exactement c'est le valais fientes de
l'état qui a eu la gentillesse de me
apportés alors naturellement je me suis
permis d'emprunter quelques billets dans
votre portefeuille pour le récompenser
parce qu'il a été biya du bir on mettra
ça sur la note un manteau de fourrure en
plein mois de juillet mais comme je suis
en dessous c'est supportable
vous êtes nul sous huy et fait sorti
comme ça oui
un tel manque de pudeur mais enfin vous
qui dément de plusieurs îles forte
volonté manqué de pudeur c'est pas mon
cas est en fait remettre votre lit jama
alors que non non non non non bon moment
d'ailleurs je ne vous dérangera pas plus
longtemps on et vous de me dire aussi je
vais chercher une autre chambre l'hôtel
et celle ci saura vous du savoir
la jaquette oui de la porte depuis ce
matin
oui monsieur désiré un petit déjeuner
mai à 20h30 c'était un peu osé alors je
me suis permis de lui apporter un petit
poulet froid
claverie mais il est parti il est parti
oui alors je lui apporte un poulet il me
pose un lapin par des entrées si
monsieur vient donner la peine de
refermer la porte je vous prie je vous
remercie infiniment appeler madame
monsieur c'est bien ici lâche entre eux
deux cents à 45
mais oui monsieur et lâche entre 245 et
bien et celle de monsieur pierre rolland
oui mais sur un lundi matin
il vient de partir cela tendrait donc
bien mais je n'ai pas de chance je n'ai
vraiment pas de chance juge pourrait
excuser moi des ponts levis d'une
opinion nous c'est une firme ma femme
mes dupond et moi-même appartenant à
deux des plus vieilles familles
protestantes de en unissant nous
destinée nous avons fondé la fin de
conserve du pont levis que je n'ai pas
besoin de vous présenter encore une fois
puis-je c'est que je souffre d'un
traumatisme des côtés extérieurs du
cinquième métatarsien du pied droit
c'est triste quoi tout le monde est
aperçu mais ça ne se voit pas mais j'ai
quand même triste
m mieux que quiconque étant donné votre
état de santé
vous pouvez me concentre trouvé que j'ai
mauvaise mi pas précisément mais pour
porter un manteau tourillon par une
pareille chaleur je pense que vous devez
être assez est touché c'est triste oui
enfin au nom est une parente nous est
une amie de monsieur roland une amie oui
vous le connaissez dont bien comme moi
même et je ne vous demande de me
répondra que si vos le juger opportun
qu'est ce que vous pensez de lui c'est
un garçon parfait c'est tous les
rapports à un peu foufou apic goy à la
baballe pas énormément si dans les idées
et alors à ses coureurs
mais enfin par cette petite taille là
vraiment de détails
il en est pourri je sais et c'est là que
gît le g cadre à ces drames assez triste
écoutez je ne vous demande rien mais si
ça peut vous soulager vraiment à votre
coeur étant donné votre état de santé
est encore bien bonne de vous intéresser
à mes petites affaires personnelles
je vous alors je vous disais donc voyons
qu est ce que je disais avait livré ses
frais donc monsieur redan ingénieur chez
du pont levis depuis dix ans c'est lui
entre autres cas découvert les fameux
fermeture éclair autant termes éthiques
de nos boîtes de conserve
monsieur roland des jeux m'avez fait
l'honneur de demander la main de ma
fille marie marguerite un âge moyen de
neige tombées du ciel danois de mariage
au complet mais veut puisque tout en
faisant le bonheur de la vie je
m'attachais a jamais monsieur roland
comme ingénieur la cérémonie devait
avoir lieu un concert
tous les dupondt tous les lévy attendait
à la mairie l'arrivée et défiguré poupe
on est conduit au temps non non non à
l'église
j'avais fait ce grand sacrifice à mon
futur gendre et pendant ce temps là
savez vous ce qu'il faisait mon futur
gendre à nous mais ils dormaient ou 1
c'est incroyable syrie et non non non
non c'est risible
votre
je commence à comprendre que vous ne
soyez pas trop incommodés par la chaleur
et vous vous promenez comme ça devant
monsieur renaud on va vous savez je fais
très attention à ce que mon manteau ne
s'ouvrent pas à piste un ami d'enfance
oui bien sûr un ami d'enfance
mais monsieur rolland et bien non on va
c'est parce qu'il est de la recherche
d'une chambre dans un autre hôtel
il veut abandonner celle ci oui mais
pourtant pas mal c'est sans doute alors
votre présence qui il agrémentera les
yeux monsieur dupont le vilain non non
alors je dis non non non non non pas du
pont levis et dupont
les sites avec un trait d'union
c'est une galanterie vaisseau nippon oui
j'avais dans ma jeunesse
la réputation de tourner assez joliment
le madrigal mais las les affaires ma vie
dit vous étiez dans la conserve en effet
alors vous connaissez sans doute la
firme beau fils et fils
c'est à koné ah oui j'avais beau fils et
filles c'est mon pire ennemi et et ussel
plus déloyales et confère je sors une
nouvelle marque de tomates
il sort une nouvelle marque de haricots
verts eu de nouvelles parts et pinard
800 une nouvelle marque de petits points
mais c'est dégoûtant sans compter que
depuis deux ans beau fils et fils a tout
mis en oeuvre pour m'arracher à prix
d'or monsieur ho non profit ses fils
c'est le malheur de match mais vous
m'avez demandé si je connaissais beau
fils et fils mais vous le connaissez
tous mènent bain
il m'a été donné de rencontrer quelques
fois edgar chez des amis gars vous
appelez vos fils et fils est gay mais
c'est son nom edgar je ne me vois pas
très bien la plan is it da visiteurs
pour président je ne sais pas lady
isidore comme j'aurais muzito c'est mon
prénom
vous vous appelez ici tous je m'appelle
isidore à la cheville
isidore mais ne trouvez pas que c'est un
peu triste isidore tu vises mésidor si
c'est très très bon c'est la vie qui
éclatent au grand jour ici isidore ici
oui c'est sans doute alors la femme qui
la crise en prononçant aussi sur moi ça
ait jamais vous m'entendez mademoiselle
jeanne mais depuis nous sommes mariés
julien entendu mon prénom prononcé avec
un peu de sympathie avec un soupçon que
de tendresse ne trouvez pas que c'est
triste a dit dan
merci souvenirs à mon ami dans le oui
c'est pierre lang
oui oui il faut vous lui trouvez
vraiment une très très grande valeur
personnelle pour vouloir comme ça vous
la tâche est accomplie mais je le trouve
tellement qu'il remplace avec eux je
suis venu en cachette de ma femme lui
dire que j'étais prêt à lui ouvrir mes
bras et un retrait suite et marie
marguerite dans les siens coc lui n'ont
certainement pas fier n'est pas la
première fois que sa chambre un trait
mais je vous en fait j'ai toujours sur
moi un crayon du papier et ça alors je
ne perds jamais mon temps et le temps
c'est de l'argent
la dame à qui j'avais emprunté le
manteau est rentré plus tôt que le plus
que prévu elle a été directement à son
armoire elle s'est aperçue de l'emprunt
alors j'ai apporté celui-ci à 1 3 l elle
libère quand tenez vous avez vous
regretté de prendre celui là dans la
mort de madame li chine ce qui est les
parties 48 heures pour lourdes nous
avons miraculeusement deux jours devant
nous voilà
alors je prends qui me permet de prendre
ces fleurs à mademoiselle je les bêta
sur le manteau avec un petit monde ma
façon comme ça elle ne portera pas
plainte
voilà échanger vos vêtements demoiselle
je suis très pressé jouer derrière le
paravent c'est sa mademoiselle je vais
me mettre à regarder le parapente voilà
enfin retourner vous mon ami voilà et
vous aussi isidore isidore parfaitement
d'isidore sait il entreprend de
réveiller non écoutés c'est pourquoi les
rapporter je vole je veux lui dire je
dois dire aussi à mademoiselle qu'il ya
une dame qui frappent à toutes les
portes de l'état de l'hôtel que je
termine par cinq en disant je suis sûr
que ça serait une part 5
alors comme vous êtes de 345 elle ne
devrait pas tarder à arriver
elle a l'air de quoi pas commode moi
c'est ma femme si elle me trouve dans
cette chambre 126 g
il vaut mieux que je m'en aille c'était
après carole ans et 6 et 10 mhz
enfin jamais je n'aurais coûte entre 100
et 200 45 et 85 président mais qui si je
demandais pas que je dirais ça ça te
tais à pardon monsieur pierre rolland
est à la recherche d'une chambre dans un
autre il déménage
il se doit il ou non de son expérience
mais qui moi avoue aussi sûrement mais
d'abord qu'est ce vous qu'est ce que
vous faites dans cette chambre et ben e
je suis heureuse de me trouver parce que
ça me procure le plaisir de vous y
recevoir parce qu'il fait chaud à
schoten vous ne trouvez pas qu'une fille
shoah non non mais vous êtes fan ou pas
à mettre un autre four soit parfait de
canicule mais enfin madame c'est pas
plus fou de forcer toutes les portes de
chambres dont les numéros se termine par
un abri sont là ne vous retient pas je
n'en dirai pas tant que je n'aurais pas
vu l' ignoble individu qui a failli être
en onze ans que je ne mentirai pas bien
alors on va l'attendre ensemble pour
avoir un thème toupet il faut
certainement que vous ayez des droits et
des droits sérieux sur monsieur roland
qu'ils s'étaient vous un soi-disant
sommeil réparateur et mon mari mon épée
fils de marie qui chercher des excuses à
ces misérables qui voulait rattraper la
faire c'est du mariage de votre fils
mais dieu merci je suis là avec moi pas
de pitié ce sera où la rupture avec
cette misérable où la cassure définitive
entre les dupont et lévis et si les
dupondt s'envoler les biscuits
et ma pauvre petite fille qu on ne sut
pas tellement amies s'agit pas de vous
mais de ma fille marie marguerite ou
encore une déception non pour vous au
contraire tout s'arrange vous allez tous
vous faire épouser par votre amant mais
je n'ai pas tellement besoin avait
préféré cumulé siffler ou un coup
puissant rien vous cacher je connais la
vie moi mais ça fait mais ce relent pour
en atteindre la bagatelle
et puis un vieux pour sa chute
sam pas cinq mais bon ça comment nous
sommes pas sur le mieux venez vite tout
vous expliquent ils à huy à l'arrière-
bien entendu là naturellement à sa
pauvre femme oh mais elle ne sait rien
vous avez vous mais c'est lui qui m'a
dit c'est un homme bien vous savez
généreux sensible discret si je vous
disais qu'il n'a jamais voulu me dire
son prénom suffit
c'est pas de gaîté de coeur croyez le
bien que je mène cette existence double
nous autres femmes honnêtes à qui la vie
a toujours souri vous ne pouvez pas
savoir ce que c'est que la vie du profit
comme moi sans argent madame s'emparant
sans famille sans espoir alors qu'eux
mêmes ne comptez pas sur moi pour vous
plaire aux je sais je sais appartenir à
deux hommes à la fois si l'on tue c'est
vrai ma vie à moi toujours été une ligne
de toit une ligne de petites vitesses et
dieu soit loué chamarré qui conçoit la
vie exactement comme moi
depuis combien de temps vous êtes marié
lévy 27 ans et trois mois et en 27 ans
et trois mois
bien sûr vous vous êtes certaine que
votre mari n'a jamais pensé à prendre
une petite route secondaire les berlines
tout droit tout cinq pur ça n'ont jamais
compté pour nous que notre fille et deux
concerts au s'émerveille alors vous
pouvez comprendre qu'elle crève coeur ce
serait pour moi que des données massives
à ce coureur de coquilles oui en effet
sa brique celui là n'est tard j'ai
failli y apprenons une petite tâche est
d'autant plus volontiers que c'est moi
qui les ai payées il va vous savez doit
avoir du mal à trouver une chambre
d'hôtel puis c'est tout
vous êtes tous tenus ce votre manteau et
moi depuis dix minutes je parle jeunes
qui tous plus ou sont mortes et pas
avant demain on tue un service qu'il
faut que je puisse délivrer le vieux bah
oui parce que vous comprenez monsieur
roland avant de connaître et consentir à
nous prendre pour mon nom que j'évite
autant que possible que les deux hommes
se rencontrent évidemment c'est gênant
bah oui alors si c'était pas trop abuser
de votre gentillesse
vous demanderez d'avoir l'amabilité de
vous cacher quelques instants un juste
le temps pour moi de faire sortir le
vieux la salle de bains et d'expédier
mort je pensais plus à une compromission
près merci c'est pas par vous que je le
fais c'est pour sa pauvre femme bon
alors alors alors est ce que je me mêle
mettez-vous derrière les paravents un
regard de paravent si je m'en vais dans
un lupanar
s'il vous plaît madame surtout ne faites
pas de bruit un le pauvre vieux serait
fou d espoir s'il se pose est quelqu'un
ait pu le voir mais venez vite mais
depuis les marchés mondiaux
ou c'est toi levier à mes yeux c'était
un traquenard rôle avec ma fille soit
avec la maîtresse de mon ex futur gendre
je n'ai jamais été l'amour de cette
personne qui va peut-être nous faire
croire à nancy que c'est agnès libanais
qui m'habite russe
alors si pendant les petits pois et
haricots verts que cette créature se
reçoit toute nue sous son manteau le
sumo a expliqué maman faisait pas
attendre et ensuite à voilà ma vie ma
vie depuis 27 ans et demi je ne trouvais
pas de ces tristes heures si isidore si
si je vous avais dit de moi que je
connaissais son prénom
tout ça va se payer en blanc que les
vitraux dans l'intérêt de la suisse je
consens pire est peut-être à ne pas
divorcer je versais mais à une condition
que les filles c'est d'auto du pont de
aux provenances action quoi en deux ou
trois actions c'est pas grand chose mais
c'était même suffisant pour faire passer
la majorité entre les mains des mutins
c'est un lundi matin étant donné le
travail que j'ai fourni c'est nous qui
devrions avoir la majorité est posé mes
conditions c'est non à mon pardon il ya
longtemps que les dupont préparer ce
coût en mana de cousineau qui a monté
cette fille dans mon bras
entrée je viens dire à benoît c'est que
madame vichy au maire des raisons encore
il me disait que je serai t parler
parler de tes parents galèrent avait
raison quand elle me déconseillaient ce
mariage était même triste d'en arriver
là pour une simple question de la tva
c'est très trop facile de tromper
ignominieusement sa femme
ignominieusement sa femme celui de
débauche pu continuer ensemble sont et
intérêts pas là la devise et dupont
turpitudes et trahisons voilà là
d'éviter deux jours je voudrais quand
même dire à mademoiselle
bien je laisse ces messieurs dames alors
que rennes deux brochettes et je sors
l'ancien manceau
mais le lendemain vous excuser robinson
ne me surprend je pense messieurs connu
nous veillons pour la dernière fois vous
pourrez passer demain à la caisse
j'aurais fait préparer le dédit du vus
vous me renvoyez ne vous rendra pas
monsieur je les chasse le nez lévis
j'attends les vies ah bon voilà maman
merci papa
hautmont coframi vous jeter comme ça la
rue sabots mina
je m'excuse mais là vous allez tout
froissé fsu c'est tout abîmé
excusez-moi j'ai zappé êtes bien nerveux
vous
10dans vous en avez la chance d'avoir
trouvé une chambre d'hôtel je n'avais
pas trouvé cet affreux ça vous allez
être obligé d'aller dormir sous les pots
remarquer peut-être que ça vous donnera
l'occasion de sauver une autre pauvre
fille qui part chagrin d'amour
ben oui ça prend d'amour neuf fois sur
dix c'est la raison pour laquelle les
jeunes filles veulent mettre fin à leurs
jours
quand même vous n'êtes pas gentil avec
moi dit pourquoi vous n'êtes pas gentil
avec moi un mois je suis gentil avec
vous je vous aide à payer vos vestes on
évite c'est quand même insensé vous ayez
autant de vêtements alors que moi je
vais plus seul rabat m remarquez il est
vrai que j'ai une chambre et vous n'avez
plus à compenser si tu désolé vous
m'envoyez 1 6 1
je voudrais pas corse qui fâchent alors
si je vous ai fait du tort à
volontairement mhb réparer
donnez moi un numéro de monsieur du pour
lévis vous avez tort
j'ai une influence considérable sur
votre ex culture beau papa ne vous
énervez pas ça sert à rien
soyez vous avez besoin de moi je vais
vous aider à les 1/2 essayé ma vie
et bah quoi va essayer aller mais enfin
temps pour moi mais c'est pas vrai y
arriver la probité
vous aviez une belle situation chez les
du pont levis on marque il est vrai
qu'en épousant la fille ne faut pas vous
désespérez pour si peu ce renvoi c'est
peut-être un mal pour un bien enfin
romont les grands remèdes
je monte préféré que je reçois votre
belle-mère au lit je vois je vois pas ce
cas particulièrement à déçoit fortement
tout comme celui dissous
mais qu'aurait pensé mon malin du policy
je l'avais reçu dans une robe déchirée
d'autant qu'elle est persuadée je suis
votre maîtresse de ce qu'elle pense que
ma commune est sûr que je suis celle de
son mari ne savait si tu d'imagina
tribun mais à faire la toilette
madame dupont les oui l'a sans doute pas
trouvé ça tout seul on a dû lui souffler
n'oubliez pas votre truc de gardénal ce
serait dommage bon bah je vous le laisse
un souvenir de moi
eh ben vous êtes bien beau mais j'ai
plus envie de me suicider voyez j'ai pas
déjeuner j'ai faim j'ai fait remonter
petite collation d'après vous êtes ici
chez vous en remercie vous êtes vraiment
trop bon avec moi oui on dit une maman
d'un service oui vous comprenez je peux
pas rester séquestrée éternellement ici
alors on est dans une boutique vous
prenez titre up quelque chose de très
sales juste pour demain et atteint la
terre ayant trait au fait monsieur mason
mais non c'était moi maintenant une
personne oui
eux voulaient voir la gentillesse de
faire monter un petit souper froid s'il
vous plaît alors pas très fan de camilla
oui quelques tranches de saumon oui une
terrine de foie gras champagne rosé et
je fais médecins bien sûr si on a trop
tard john abbott au diable les varices
ors des palais quoi comme il veut
montrer vous ferait descendre mes
bagages
ces messieurs dames s'en vont non
monsieur 120 et moi je reste ah bon
monsieur pas dans le midi pourquoi dans
le milieu ah mais j'ai l'habitude de mes
clients je je vois tout de suite laisse
pas que vous avez les girls gare
saint-lazare vous avez dit que le gars
de lyon vous avez les girls et gare de
l'est
alors monsieur a une gueule à une figure
gare de lyon sorti il ya monsieur la
gare de lyon mais ne se rend pas
j'espère que je n'oublie rien oh bah de
toute façon soyez tranquilles je trouve
un vêtement ou un objet quelconque vous
appartenant je ne remettrai au valium
merci à moins que vous préférez que je
les porte à l'adresse que vous m'a dit
créé non non non pia pia pia savais
j'aurais vraiment voulu vous connaissiez
sous un autre jour j'ai l'air comme ça
mais enfin je veux dire que quand je
suis dans mon état normal
il est dit que jusqu'au dernier moment
vous fait de la peine oui bien sûr je ne
vous connais pas depuis très longtemps
mais je connais bien oui aubin vous avez
beau user de votre physique ont trouvé
bien physiquement
la question n'est pas là oui je viens
prendre les bagages de monsieur parfait
monsieur ne sort jamais sans son or
monsieur à risque aux hôtes pour la
grande bleue le soleil les femmes les
fleurs quel dommage que je ne sois plus
le gaillard d'avant
puisque monsieur prend la vie à la
légère
voudrait-il avoir la gentillesse de
fermer la lourde et je te le tirer mais
bon adieu yvelines adieu pierre
mais revoit vous êtes fous non comme ça
oui
voilà
à
alors je remonte les bagages de monsieur
et je rajoute un couvert
rideau
[Musique]
maintenant j'aime bien dormi oui c'est
que mademoiselle a presque fait le tour
du cadran
c'est même en m'apercevant qu'il était
pas loin dès 11h45 que je me suis permis
d'apporter le petit déjeuner à
mademoiselle mademoiselle désir telle
que je la servent
loties ya fort vous faire l'offre mollet
bien sûr avoue à demi-mot vie est
normale
mademoiselle m ou telle la confiture de
pêche
sissel je ferai faire j'en étais certes
c'est normal
mademoiselle et la douceur et la
gentillesse même toute la pêche
alors que la vie de mademoiselle doit
avoir une prédilection marquée pour la
confiture de s'y trompe pas ce militaire
voilà il ya de mademoiselle désir tels
que je porte le plateau jusqu'à sa
couche cette pêche est une pêche
miraculeuse le le chef de la fait que
pour les clients d'exception merci
mademoiselle c'est bien qu'il existe
entre le oui ne savent attirer 6 3 oui
voilà bien mademoiselle désir tels que
je lui prépare une mouillette à jamais
car mademoiselle sera officiellement
seule elle ne la fera pas longtemps
n'est ce pas nos normes nous ne
resterons pas l'otan seuls
il n'y avait qu'à voir la façon dont
nous regardaient du pour le vie pour
être fixé et puis un mariage de perdu
dix de retrouvés comme l'ont dit les
patrons nous ne resteront pas longtemps
seul est un peu mieux qu'avec cet
individu qui qui par ailleurs ne manque
pas d'une certaine classe et d'une
certaine allure jeudi ravi pour son âge
monsieur là encore de beaux restes
bonjour nu au que ces villas au civil à
lille dont vous êtes plus gracieux aux
couches échos révèle on s'est rencontrés
simplement et tu n'as rien pas court
chercher à me plaire
moi moins fort vous l'aimez pas cette
chanson on dit cela ni l'eau alors se
laisse ma voix qui vous déplaît non non
non non non mais j'aimerais bien
brazey-en-plaine que votre volonté soit
faite
le fruit d'une faiblesse avec vous moi
je ne sais rien refuser aux eaux si l'on
peut dire
mais je ne vous ai rien fusée c'est vous
qui avez eu la le tac de ne pas abuser
de la situation ça n'a rien à voir
ok magazine ok la vessie non non non le
ses bras laissez moi je suis une pure
jeune fille bianca métiers via nova
après voulait pas beaucoup insisté pour
regretter en poste je n'ai pas abusé de
la situation
oui je le regrette pour vous auriez
accepté
enfin vous pourrez tout n'a pas rameuté
l'hôtel pour si peu de choses
je ne vous connais que le cuir et en 24
heures vous avez bousillé mon mariage
ppr dans ma situation quasiment montres
de marque et oussalah aucune aucune
espèce d'importance puisque on a fini un
passé la nuit ensemble vous dans le lit
et moi dans le fauteuil
allez me le dire tout de suite que vous
trouviez tard mais vous n'avez pas
laissé le temps de parler ou s'être jeté
sur moi tu as eu la chance d'être tombé
sur un jeu blanc écoutez si j'avais
pensé que vous étiez un petit peu
amoureux de moi peut-être que j'aurais
agi autrement mais avouez que je n'ai
aucune raison d'avoir la moindre ça va
des bourgs vous dites je vais vous
demander
vous ne trouvez mieux ou moins bien que
votre fiancée la question n'est pas là
dont vous trouvez mieux à physiquement
je veux dire mais marie marguerite est
une pure jeune fille elle
[Musique]
oui et pour vous il ya que le mort à
quiconque oui oui et puis aller loin
elle est très très très loin d'être
laide
en plus je ne comprends pas qu'on se
suicide mais et par amour mois-ci pas
parce que c'est par amour que
parfaitement bien bas je vous laisse je
vais chercher une chambre d'hôtel et une
situation pour l'agencé parle à peine
jours en salle si oui avez-vous à la
vente ou bien
je viens pour le plateau mademoiselle je
puis me permettre
s'il vous plaît est ce que vous me
demandez de wagram 15 22 à l'hospice
c'est un vieillard sava emily prentiss
es tu me passes wagram un kamikaze 22
abraham 15-22 s'il te plaît et les
gosses ça va en rien les oreillons rro
chevrier ça peut être dangereux et à
bagram qui ne quittez pas pas grave
merci à l'eau ah c'est toi aux dix mois
est ce que tu vas me faire porter at
ailleurs et des chaussures à l'impérial
à l'hôtel impérial jambes de 145 oui sur
245 et comment qu'est ce que je fais à
la paire ya je te dirai plus tard je te
dirai plus tard non je ne suis pas
revenu parce que je suis pas parti je
t'expliquerai plus tard comment tu veux
absolument savoir a dû exiger patator
alors je vais te dire j'ai passé la nuit
ici avec un homme là cette vente est
content voilà bien fait
aa c'est du pur lui ça non c'est un
autre oui merveilleux quel tempérament
nécessaires
c'est un jeune ça got la bel âge alors
oui à ses toiles au jour juste du jeu
c'est le concierge et dit qu'il ya
monsieur dupont le vit en va et monsieur
dupont lui vraiment et quelques minutes
fait le monte envoyée
je ne voudrais pas à m'immiscer un mois
zèle mais que compte faire mademoiselle
si quand monsieur du pont-levis sera là
l'autre 50 ans arrive il va écouter ce
sont deux hommes du monde alors je les
présenterai et bavarde
vous savez que j'ai pour mademoiselle
une admiration sans borne rentrée
monsieur est une bénédiction pour moi
monsieur l'agent du joueur revient mais
la forte merci beaucoup
merci mademoiselle de me recevoir
après une scène aussi déplacé et de vous
souvenir également que je devais rester
longtemps debout il ya 3 heures déjà
tombe à 3 à 3 heures que je guette le
départ de monsieur roland le site
c'est en effet grâce et des primes
moselle j'ai à vous entretenir de deux
questions qui tout en paraissant de
prime abord n'avoir aucun lien entre
elles se rattachent cependant très
directement à l'une à l'autre la seconde
compensant largement la première comme
vous pouvez en juger
c'est en supplie ne m'interrompez pas si
je perdais mon fils je ne le retrouverai
pas eu le marché que j'ai à vous
proposer à basculer d'un marché qu'il
s'agit et l'habitude des affaires alors
je vous demande de nous rendre monsieur
rolland à vous rendez compte combien ma
mission est pénible mais à quel titre
désirez vous récupérez monsieur alors
comme ingénieur comme jaunes tombent à
penser les devants de peur mais n'est-ce
pas votre femme qui a chassé hier
monsieur rolland la colère est souvent
mauvaise conseillère et ma femme est
très emporté très violent a remis un bon
nous le droit de priver la maison du
pont levis d'un collaborateur est
remplaçable les affaires avant tout même
avant l'amour l'amour et l'intérêt sont
à ranger dans deux chemises bien du
stack de bien séparer mais pas tellement
puisque dans l'intérêt de votre fille
vous êtes prêts à donner votre fille en
mariage un homme dont vous avez toutes
les raisons de suspecter la pause
lorsque j'ai épousé ma demoiselle dupont
nous ne pouvions pas l'un pour l'autre
l'amour démesuré ce qui nous a pas
empêché de faire un mariage tant
d'autres si je lis y échapper monsieur
roland il ne tarderait pas à être
engagés par beau fils et fils
notre concurrent direct et à il est
déloyal mais laissons là ce misérable et
revenons à notre affaire
vous avez des jambes ravissante
nous venons à rien comme c'est triste
mais oublié ce vilain mot 1,1 depuis
hier je ne cesse de penser à vos mains
en trop grand bien
ma mère président merci merci oui oui
oui oui il serait normal si vous
consentiez à nous rentrer monsieur
roland que vous ne pâtissier en rien de
sacrifices que nous apprécierions soyez
sans certaines à sa juste valeur
fille dont vous êtes d'accord sur le
principe même du roi du jeu je vous
propose joueurs je vous offre jeu je
m'offre à le remplacer auprès de vous
tant sur le plan sentimental que
pécuniairement
monsieur 10 pour les bibles et je suis
moins jeunes que lui
c'est vrai mais j'ai un petit coeur tout
neuf heures s'est apprécié à je suis en
outre dans le privé d'un naturel enjoué
le repac la mélancolie n'est
qu'apparente et vous vous ne pouvez pas
savoir ce qu'on peut obtenir dans la vie
avec la larme facile
un affaire aussi et c'est pénible de
voir plus l'autre est un homme mal est
fait et bien pour ne plus le voir
pleurer
on lui cède cette fois notre effort
monsieur 10 pour les vitres être n'est
ce pas un alors pc oui je ne sais pas ça
demande réflexion is it here aux
visiteurs
isidore lorsque vous prononcez is it or
je sens mon coeur qui cacao au monde
this is it easy rider is it or leave it
clean
si mon prénom aussi je trouve absent
mais je trouve un petit peu long alors
que vous appellerez je vous appellerai
les nouilles leur lit
elle va elle va venir te faire pleurer
10 pour les vies écourtées ses fils pas
beaucoup de moi sa fille laisse nommé
bataille
oui papa avant de vous casser la gueule
je vous ai cool dit pont levis szatny je
vous adore
mais elle elle comment at elle pu se
donner à la froide votre espèce et je
n'ai jamais été calvin la téléphonie
gagne de miel qu'elles avaient passé la
nuit à l'impérial j'ai cru que c'était
avait craint de ses mines et qui lui
faisait la cour et le dominer le service
en gigolo c'était vous à crever de rire
si ce n'était pas aussi ignoble même est
un vieillard hleb bête et prétentieux de
ce que ma fille a été choisi et si vous
continuer à brutaliser j'appelle au
secours
un conseil fermez là où je vous écrase
comme une punaise que vous êtes en
serait condamnée pour coups et blessures
et vous pour détournement de mineure
poussez pas que cette personne fut
mineur elle ne l'est pas mais je voulais
vous faire avouer que vous étiez son
amant mais ce n'est rien a fait du tour
en yvelines yvelines pour pouffer de
rire j'en fais que le voyez votre tête
sur une date de concert et des bergeries
cas que vous braves à l'idée de faire
coller votre binette seront opposés dans
les spas insensé d'attirer la clientèle
me à vous couper l'appétit oui n'empêche
qu'on me concerne ce bar de new york les
vôtres qu'est ce que vous comptez y
avait toujours été un concurrent déloyal
été loyal associé à employer ce mot
déloyale après la claque aux minables
que vous avez commis mais au fait
renault à ma fille où et quand
n'avez-vous connu hier ici un parfait
moi ça comprend adam avant dé quoi
au lieu de partir en province et ville a
pris pour une raison que j'ignore une
chambre dans cet hôtel vous l'avez suivi
vous êtes fait de lui une chambre
voisine de la sienne dès que la
malheureuse enfant était endormi vous
êtes précipité c'est énorme énorme et
laissez moi vous expliquer c'est beau
quand c'est triste
il ya longtemps que vous n'aviez pu
placer celui là mais mais avec moi ça ne
prend pas je ne suis pas du four l'enjeu
qui pour le plus vous entendre gémir a
pris trois mille boîtes d'aspères jabbi
fra la boîte le 2 sept
encore une de vos intentions ça les
valait vendus mais à serge plus de 7
francs la boîte alors que vous vendez
votre 750 et qu'elles sont d'une qualité
très intérieur viennent vous osez
prétendre monsieur comme et jasper je ne
veux pas les votants avaient aussi bien
que moi elles sont pourries
d'hypocrisies prouver son pourtour
méfiez-vous du pont levis kinect pourri
pour alvaro j'ai abusé de cette
malheureuse enfant tu es toi papa je ne
me tairais pas j'ai ce que nous envoie
qu'est ce que tu veux dire d'abord parce
que ce monsieur n'a jamais été dans la
moi mais si mademoiselle et qu'il avait
l'intention de le devenir
je ne pouvais pas penser que j'avais à
faire à la fille beau fils et fils fait
chez vous si vous aviez comme moi
trouvez votre fille dans la chambre du
fiancé matic il se promenant nu sur un
manteau de fourrure à faire vous ne
l'auriez pas pris pour une vertu ta
bouche que ce que vous racontez mais
qu'est ce que c'est que cette histoire
la vérité n'a pas les écoutes fait tout
raconter mais jouera d'abord que ce
monsieur s'en aille
oui vous ne sentez pas que vous êtes de
trop du pont levis je m'en faire je vous
laisse en famille une famille qui tom
fausse asperges et pour rio
tel est l'homme en question
pierre rolland là je veux dire de celle
du pont levis oui et tué sa maîtresse
non alors bon sens avec qui a dû passer
la nuit
mais avec pierre rolland à je ne mettrai
pas plus longtemps et devine que tu te
moques de moi mais je ne mens pas toi
nous avons passé la nuit ici moi dans le
lit il lui dans fauteuils je suis
simplement pour avoir le plaisir de
dormir dans la même chambre que toi
culte a offert son manteau de fourrure
mais c'est bon il n'a pas été offert par
monsieur relancer celui d'adams chinsky
mais qu'est ce que cette femme bien pire
dans cette histoire mais tu mélanges
tout c'est toi qui mélange doux
assieds toi non non non je t'écoute
alors voilà au lieu d'aller me reposer
48 heures chez tante je suis allé me
jeter dans la seine
mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire te jeter dans la seine
mais pour quelle raison et eut commis
par une folie que je ne te crois pas car
chagrin d'amour
ça m'étonnerait la non tu es une femme
trop propre équilibre et draw femme
d'affaires trop intelligent mais surtout
trop femme d'affaires
un propos en parlant à faire le dernier
marché de sardines que tu as traité a
coûté huit mille fois un bon fils et
fils parce que tu as vendu trop bon
marché parce que j'avais acheté trop
chaleur d'un coup papa on sera jamais
d'accord là dessus il ya deux ans quand
tu m'as pris comme associé il a été
convenu que je m'occupais des achats et
toi des votes c'est donc à tous à de
vendre plus cher c'est enfantin
tu sais parfaitement ma petite fille que
la marque bénéficiant pas dit s'il te
plait pas mort le deux roues il alors
alors comme je ne veux pas que tu me
reproches éternellement ce manque à
gagner
j'ai décidé de te rembourser sur mes
bénéfices de fin d'année le soi-disant
déficit des sables message vient
l'argent lorsque tu habilles l état en
jeu mon petit chat papa avant qu'il soit
longtemps je vais apporter des millions
à notre firme evelyn evelyn tous mes
frères écoutez je me suis jeté dans la
seine
ou bien c'était pour éviter le mariage
de pierre rolland avec mademoiselle
du bon lead quoi alors une fois remplie
si parler mais repêchée par qui
m'appartient relire décidément tu
comprends rien ce matin je voudrais voir
à ma place
vient alors il m'a repêché hisser sur la
berge mis dans un taxi s'est assis à
côté de moi et là je n'ai plus qu'à le
mettre ko
ah oui mais du mal mais comment quand et
si tu tiens alors tu l'avais déjà
rencontré démontre une fois sur les
champs-elysées exact je me souviens même
que tu m'avais dit en parlant nuit d'un
temps assez méprisant d'ailleurs c'est
sa pierre rolland qui sabre mais tu ne
l'a rêvé oui enfin passons le mariage
ait craqué admettons mais tout ça
n'implique pas que monsieur pierre
rolland entrera pour autant dans notre
famille assis j'ai compris tu veux
l'épouser
je lève il me l'affairé dans sa ville
magnifique
mademoiselle à mademoiselle
oui bravo la gentillesse de dire au
portier de prier monsieur roland de
remonter aux 240 merci mademoiselle papa
je te demande de prendre l'air sur une
furieuse de quoi de la nuit que monsieur
roland m'a contrainte à passer avec lui
mais il ya certainement lui entré
s'évalue
je viens rechercher le manteau qu'elle
manteau de meunerie chine cité majesty
tu la connais non ah bon
si la page a fois que je vois à
mademoiselle dans une tenue normale et
je dois dire que ça lui va bien
également
oui merci voilà me prenais le messie
j'espère que nous aurons le plaisir de
revoir mademoiselle de temps à autre je
ne crois pas
enfin à moins que nous venions passé ici
notre nuit de noces
parce que mademoiselle va se marier
sûrement et pourrais je savoir qui est
l'heureuse élue je vous promets que
votre curiosité sera entièrement
satisfaites avant que je m'en aille
mademoiselle est bien une aubaine
on voit l'effet demandé en effet mais
d'abord permettez moi de vous présenter
monsieur beau fils et ce fils de vokoun
mais ben je vais vous dire une bonne
chose monsieur beau fils et fils ça fait
20 ans vous emmerder le monde
de plus vous êtes incapables et j'irai
même plus loin
vous n'aviez pas eu votre papa avant
vous vous ne sauriez ayad du tout
décidément vous me plaisait beaucoup
monsieur pierre rolland mini concours
mais comme quoi vous êtes un vieux con
un vieux pont un vieux con c'est mon
papa c'est mon papa
oui où
[Musique]
pourquoi m'avoir cette comédie parce que
je ne voulais pas vous épousez
mademoiselle du pont levis ne vous plaît
pas écoutez si vous comprenez pas c'est
vraiment vous êtes un imbécile
monsieur beau fils et fils j'ai pu dire
sous la colère que vous étiez un vieux
con c'est faux vous n'êtes pas vu du
tout est encore très vert jeune homme
j'exige des excuses mais ses excuses je
les veux cet après midi même à 4 heures
devant tout mon personnel mais je je je
je serai en avant ce monsieur bons
offices efficient quand il va voulait
pas vu du tout je suis vraiment désolé
d'avoir pu dire bien je souhaitais plus
un mot mon cher directeur commercial à
aa1 tête à l'air devient évident
oui papa
à moi à moins que pierre ait besoin de
moi pour défaire ses valises
non merci mademoiselle je m'en sortirai
tout seul aussi si je suis très mal
avoir avoir évident pour regarder j'ai
l'impression que ces maladresses laval
toutes les adresses de la terre
mademoiselle est conserve la chambre
pour la nuit prochaine pour la vie
entière à bascule oui a alors il a fini
par se décider
et oui ça lui est un coup dur pour vous
ça ac oui on vous allez vous sentir bien
seul maintenant réglé tout potro et dont
nous vous savez ils ont été très gentils
jusqu'où ils m'ont demandé de venir
vivre avec
[Musique]
la pièce que nous avons eu le plaisir de
jouer pour vous ce soir et de raoul
praxis
les décors de jean pierre se r
[Applaudissements]
les costumes de donald cardwell
la mise en scène et de christian duroc
avec marcel schaerbeek
pascal masotti
[Applaudissements]
yvonne clech
bruno balle
en plat
et georges beller
et puis godillots
[Musique]